Huawei is very dangerous rarely does a
country go to war with a private company
we have met the enemy and it is Huawei
but America has done just that
represents a national security route but
is this really about Huawei or is it
something bigger than that
it's not can you trust Huawei it's can
you trust the Chinese government and
what is the threat this is exactly what
China wants they want to divide Western
alliances through bits and bytes not
bullets and bombs may be somewhat
sensible to open it yet so what is this
wall really about and why is Huawei in
the middle of it founded in China in
1987 Huawei is now the world's largest
maker of telecoms equipment with
revenues exceeding one hundred and three
billion dollars when you think about qua
way you might think about the handset
that makes sense
since it sold 200 million of them in
2018 alone but close to half of its
revenue comes from selling network
equipment and it's this infrastructure
side of the company that worries
governments for much more than the sort
of consumer handset side with Ericsson
and Nokia is one of the three biggest
manufacturers of this equipment in fact
since 2014
it's outgrown all its competitors
reaching over three billion people
this is how networks function your phone
sends a signal to a nearby tower using
radio waves voice and data are passed
over an internal network run by your
phone company which connects your
handset to other phone users and the
wider Internet in other words these
antennas connect us all but now there's
a new kind of network the race to 5g is
moving forward at full speed from TV ads
to presidential tweets
you've probably heard debates about the
revolutionary 5g although 5g is
massively overhyped
it is coming and Huawei is a leading
force in this innovation it will be a
sort of big change maybe not quite so
enormous as as people like to tell you
the other thing that people like to say
that 5 you will enable is this idea of
the Internet of Things if you want
things like self-driving cars that
download detailed maps where they're
about to be you need 5g to do that if
you want Internet connected door locks
or CCTV cameras maybe five years away to
connect those but though this
computerized smart future opens up new
possibilities it comes with a health
warning we're moving to a world where
everything will be connected to the
Internet but we haven't thought enough
about security that's the big fear about
having a hostile power control your 5g
network because if entire networks are
vulnerable this opens the door to
countries spying and then another
5g networks must be secure there must be
strong they have to be guarded from the
enemy in a rare interview with The
Economist run Jiang Fei huawei's founder
and CEO talks about the political storm
surrounding his company
maybe someone sent somebody open eg a
teacher go and see their video which is
a seeker some juice or something that's
legal congee what it sends a hawker a
seekers home
as the argument rages over the security
of Huawei's products the effects can be
seen in some unexpected places the
biggest issue I think with all of this
political turmoil surrounding the Huawei
name is uncertainty jofre now runs
Eastern Oregon telecom a small network
serving the people of this rural area in
rural remote areas it's hard to connect
with people and so the internet becomes
this really important way to connect
with community herb how you doing is
that the network here relies on the
huawei technology you see you're using
the internet from Eastern Oregon telecom
to be able to run monitor control all of
these pivot irrigation systems I have no
idea the Huawei equipment was 30 to 40%
less than everything else on the market
and it's more capable and more reliable
this economic boob that's out here all
of this effective agriculture that's
going on out here would not be effective
or even possible without internet
connectivity it's a similar story around
the world mobile phone users in
developing countries have benefited from
Huawei's attractive deals but how is far
away undercutting its competitors Wow I
can offer cheaper prices because they
are heavily subsidized by the Chinese
government
these are allegations that are
strenuously denied by Huawei Wow it is a
hard way to much a stronger demand by
way to tabular to Muhammad Ali Jo Gwang
know whether or how far away is
connected to and subsidized by the
Chinese government is unclear but what
is clear is this China is the kind of
country
if the party says jump all you can say
is well how high loyalty to the state is
actually enshrined in China's
intelligence law article seven a 2017
edition states that any organization or
citizen shall support assist and
cooperate with the state intelligence
work critics say this law means that
when you buy Huawei equipment you may be
exposing yourself to surveillance by the
Chinese intelligence services and this
makes government's very uncomfortable
Wow is just a tool of the Chinese
government China is a difficult country
for any company to be independent in and
when you look at that the new
intelligence are you've got to have some
concerns this has made a lot of people
worried that Huawei given its close
relationship to the Communist Party and
given the Communist Party's willingness
to wield hard power you could then end
up in a situation where they can use
that effectively as a weapon the fear is
that Huawei will leave backdoor
vulnerabilities in its networks there
would provide China with an opportunity
to spy on its competitors and enemies to
counter this mistrust Huawei has shared
its code and allowed the likes of
Britain's national cybersecurity center
to scan it for backdoors we do have
researches to go through with a
fine-tooth comb looking for exactly
these they never found anything like
that even so the Trump administration
remains suspicious
Huawei is something that's very
dangerous president Trump's escalating
trade war with China so if there's no
solid security threat why is America
making an enemy out of Huawei we cannot
allow any other country to out-compete
the United States in this powerful
industry of the future at least part of
this is motivated by desire to slow
China's rise and to keep a world in
which America is the dominant power for
as long as possible it seems as though
the concern over Huawei is not only
about America's security but also its
insecurity and it's causing collateral
damage at home as well as abroad in May
2019 the Trump administration issued an
executive order which not only forbade
American companies from supplying Huawei
with components but restricted domestic
networks from using its equipment it's a
move that feels like an own-goal to
Americans like Joe for now
worst case scenario is there's an
all-out ban that means that three to six
communities that are struggling
desperate for broadband connectivity
missing out on economic development
opportunities having young people flee
their community and never come back
it would be a huge hit and there's
another uncomfortable truth this America
can't ignore smartphone technology
relies on a truly global supply chain
take an average smartphone some contain
components from more than 200
international suppliers screens might be
made by Samsung in South Korea the
camera lens engineered in Germany the
chip could be designed by a
california-based company and
manufactured in Taiwan the battery could
come from Japan and the audio chip from
China but increasingly hostility and
lack of trust threaten to fracture these
supply chains this goes beyond Huawei we
are entering a period of increased
vulnerability when it comes to
cybersecurity in the Internet
America's concerns about Kwame are
understandable but the risks can be
managed by limiting the use of Huawei
equipment to less sensitive parts of 5g
networks that way it is possible to
benefit from the low cost of Huawei's
equipment while minimizing security
concerns you know we start talking about
withdrawing and only doing business with
companies that are really close allies
or companies that are in the United
States that damages the the global
economy and the way that we function is
a world billions of people around the
world have benefited from increased
connectivity made possible by global
standards and global supply chains
but if political mistrust devised the
telecoms industry into rival camps
everybody stand to lose if you want to
learn more about Huawei you can click on
the link opposite where you'll find
further economic coverage and some
research data and studies used to make
this film thanks for watching if you
want to see more films like this then
hit the subscribe button in the link
below
[Music]